we have been talking a little bit about
it's nice we had the same set for eight
years yes we decided to change it up and
as I said at the top of the show one of
the nice things is that it's it's a
flexible set it's it's more intimate
we're closer to the audience yeah we are
but one of the really cool things is
that if we want to we can get even
closer still to the audience you know
really be right there next time because
I just pant I'm kind of a creep and a
perv oh yeah you're you're you're not
above stealing their object no no I gave
the glasses back okay but what I like is
getting as close as I can if I want to
sure and I don't think these people
would mind if I got it oh no let's move
this whole tech fellas do you mind this
whole set moves closer if we feel the
needle it's an audience isn't giving us
[Applause]
we are
what an amazing people
it's amazing radical now now they can
really see how much work we've had done
yeah exactly and Ian I've had a lot of
work done and like I said I borrowed
that guy's glasses at the top of the
show yeah if I watch you right now let's
say I wanted to borrow like someone's
watch is there someone who's willing to
let me borrow their watch
take the sir let me take take your watch
off right there look at this let's say I
just want to just check out his watch
sir come on put some put the watch on
there sir come on John he's gonna make
me get up just put it right there on
that hook right there and then I get the
watch and then whoa
it's this this feels like the opposite
of being on a Mardi Gras flight people
are gonna use this every night it's
called the gravity's nice yeah thank you
very much for that I think he's a little
worried that he's not getting it bad and
now that I now that I've touched it I'm
complicit yeah this is great I like this
this is very nice but let's say the
audience gets sick of seeing us this way
we can always pull ourselves back right
let's say we do that guys can take it
back a little bit let's say we start to
move back now they're booing they don't
like that
see it felt like that was losin him yeah
yeah I felt like I was losing him a bit
and I can move forward and what I'm
gonna have them work on is I'm gonna
have them work on putting treads on this
thing so we can drive it up into the
audience and I can get to the back row
right listen ladies and gentlemen in the
process of getting back there are a lot
of people in these lower rows will be
killed well they'll be proud sure
they'll be crushed but that's part of
the fun of watching the show every night
and eventually we will be out on the
streets of Burbank terrorizing yeah
exactly
I think pinching people with the grabba
yeah let's keep it here for now I kind
of like it all right yeah we look weird
in this frame but I like it I'm gonna
take it anyway I can hear this man's
heart beating right now guy in the green
shirt right there it's just yes I hear
cells dividing in the audio here
everything I smell onion ring I smell
onion rings - he's got onion rings you
could also see you can see individual
people I can tell that guy right there
back there in the beard I'm guessing his
name's Nick I bet he's a big fan big fan
is it Nick I just watch as guests I
couldn't know got it now it is now yeah
I'm gonna call you Nick all right but
this is nice - let's say the guest isn't
give me anything I jump out and I start
talking to random people in the audience
nice I say sorry fitty cent you didn't
bring it today I'm going to these people
that's the kind of show you're watching
now
you